hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from the world
rapid Championship it is a round two
game between former 2700 player Dennis
kis matulin and uh world champion Magnus
Carlson a world rapid Champion as he is
the reigning world rapid and Blitz
champion and we will see if he's able to
to hold on to those titles now first
game of course I'm going to show is by
Magnus and then every other game I will
show is by you guys using the hashtag
suggestion and before we dive into this
game uh I would just like to show you
the venue uh so you see you know how
players uh are treated this is the
second game between Magnus and Dennis uh
you can see um I think that is yeah
that's widler and tar in the background
and also to the right the aort is
spotted but I don't know who he is
playing against uh and also here you can
see Magnus checking out the traditional
Wares you know he he never shes away
from that and uh yeah always some
wonderful photos I might even use this
one for the thumbnail uh but that being
said uh let's check out the game and
remember for every next game I check out
and I'm probably going to show like two
three maybe even four games a day as a
lot a lot of games will be played do use
that hashtag suggestion so let's check
it out uh it's 15 minutes per player uh
plus 10 seconds increment I'm also
allowing the clocks to be seen as uh you
know can be very relevant so uh Dennis
has the white pieces and he opens with
D4 and Magnus strikes with Knight to F6
uh and also uh I don't know if you guys
uh know this but I'll lza has been
spotted playing a tournament not this
one at the different tournament in
France uh the the Rowan open and I'm
guessing he will try to qualify for that
candidates tournament and overtake
Wesley as the number one uh highest
rated player to qualify for the
candidates tournament we'll see what
happens I will keep you guys updated so
Knight to F6 uh C4 E6 Knight to F3 and
pawn to D5 so the standard Queen's
Gambit declined is on the board we have
Knight C3 and pawn to C6 now going for
the semi slav defense we have E3 and
then Knight B to D7 and queen to C2
known as the schz variation uh Magnus
goes B6 prepares either Bishop B7 or
Bishop to A6 depending on how white
develops we have C captures C captures
and now Knight to B5 putting pressure on
that C7 Square so Bishop to B4 check
again all been play before nothing new
here Bishop to D2 Magnus trads here
captures captures and now castles and
you don't really gain anything by
advancing the knights to C7 or or even
the queen into C7 it has been tried
before and doesn't really do all that
much for white so Queen Bishop to E2 and
now Magnus plays Bishop to A6 which is
again uh weird but it is the top move in
the position and the idea is that if you
if you challenge the bishop of course
now you're not going to bring the bishop
back you actually will give up Bishop
for Knight you will play A6 put the
queen on C7 put the uh The Rook on C8
quickly claim that C file as the C1
square is not covered yet uh and that's
sort of the the game plan but instead we
have castles here and now Magnus just
captures on B5 unprovoked and it is now
as of move 12 that we have a completely
new game so Magnus concedes a little bit
here uh but you know he just wants to
play a nice game so captures captures we
have Pawn to A6 Bishop captures on D7
trading further and now Rook F to C1
claiming the C file Magnus does the same
Rook F to C8 and now Queen to D1 we have
Queen to B5 putting pressure on the B2
pawn and then is defend it with Rook to
C2 and now it's time to figure out a
game plan and that like I said in the
previous video and the video before that
and before that it usually involves a
move with the night back so it's time to
improve the position of the Knight
Knight to E8 the Knight comes to D6
where it will cover more Central squares
also gain access to E4 and C4 uh Knight
to F3 and now Rook captures and C2
Magnus trades a pair of Rooks we have
Queen captures and now Knight to D6 we
have Pawn to A4 uh chasing away magnus's
queen queen back to E8 and now Queen to
C7 quickly infiltrating with an attack
on the B6 Pawn so Queen to d8 Magnus
defends and now just Rook to C1 then it
says all right we can trade Queens but
if you trade Queens I'm getting my Rook
to an active C7 square and interestingly
Magnus goes for it we have Queen
captures on C7 Rook captures and now
Rook to C8 making uh uh trade sort of
obligatory as if you if you attack the
Knight then Rook to C1 will result in
white getting checkmated so here we have
the trade Rook captures Knight captures
and now Knight to E5 and this is the
position that Magnus got uh not the not
the most promising one of course with
the perfect play it should end in a draw
but Magnus does have 9 minutes on the
clock as you can see here and Dennis has
3 minutes and 41 seconds so let's see if
Magnus can push for something here Pawn
to F6 Knight back to D3 and King to F7
of course it's time to bring the king
into the game King to F1 Denis does the
same King E7 King to E2 and King to D6
with have Pawn to F4 not allowing Magnus
to execute Pawn to E5 and now Pawn to A5
stopping Pawn to B4 also takes away the
the B4 and the uh C5 squares from the
white knight uh Pawn to G4 we have King
to C6 and now Pawn to H4 even we have
Knight to D6 and now Pawn to H5 Pawn to
H6 by Magnus and now Pawn to B3 again
taking away B5 and C4 for magnus's
knight uh Magnus goes back King to D7
you could Advance the pawn to B5 but um
uh if you do that you also weaken the C5
Square then the Knight can come to C5
then he can pressure your E6 Pawn so
Magnus will have to figure out if if
that's what he wants to do and when he
wants to do it so he goes back King to
D7 and now Knight to F2 both players
will have to find moves and that of
course will waste time and now Magnus
strikes with Pawn to F5 and okay Pawn to
G5 now Magnus goes back King to C6 can
he get something here Knight to D3 now
going for that E5 square and now Knight
to E4 we have Knight to E5 with check
and now King to D6 and this is where it
gets very interesting now you should uh
move the king like King to F3 and then
the game continues however G captures on
H6 with played also gets a nice question
mark Here and Now magnus's position is
uh well better and leaning towards
winning G captures on H6 was played now
comes Knight to F6 go sorry first comes
um King to D3 and now Knight to F6
Magnus goes after the H5 Pawn King back
to C3 now Knight captures on H5 and okay
Magnus does get a pass H Pawn but still
a knight should be able to hold that uh
we have Pawn to B4 and now Knight to G3
making room for the past Pawn to start
marching forward uh B captures on E5
here with B5 it's still it still could
be very tricky but after B captures on
E5 uh he just allows Magnus a bit too
much but it still looks very hard look
at this B captures on A5 uh and now uh
King to D3 uh what do you what do you
play here the the problem is even if you
go for something like Knight to F7 check
King to E7 and you eliminate the pawn
let's say Knight captures here uh Knight
to E4 with check and the there's really
not all that much you can do here or
even if Knight to E5 let's say Knight to
E4 with check King D3 now King to D6
it's just um uh completely winning King
C2 King to C7 and after King D3 King to
B6 Knight to G6 now King to C6 and after
Knight f8 a king to D6 and um uh yeah
it's just uh uh the Knight will be remed
over to C4 and you will not be able to
to to defend both E3 and the A4 Pawn
once the Knight attacks it but uh
something like that actually happened in
the game after B captures on A5 uh King
to D3 was played and now H5 not going
after the pawn uh Knight to G6 as he
thought that he will be able to stop the
pawn we have Knight to E4 and now King
to C2 we have Knight to F6 uh and now
King to C3 Knight to D7 and now Knight
to H4 so he says all right my king is uh
keeping an eye on both of the weaknesses
and the King side the Knight will not be
able to do anything and this Knight is
blockading magnus's Pawn so how how is M
Magnus to break through here well he
goes Knight B6 attacks the A4 Pawn King
to B3 defending it and now Knight to C4
puts pressure on E3 and look at this you
often we say that you need the the the
at least two weaknesses to win an
endgame and here there are actually
three weaknesses this is weak this is
weak and of course the past H Pawn is
one weakness that white has to worry
about but now comes Knight to G2
defending on E3 defending on A4 and also
stopping the the pawn push but now
Magnus finds Knight to D2 with check
King to C3 and Knight to F3 now the
Knight covers the H4 square and that's
pretty much all there is it was in this
position on move 50 that Denis kis
matulin resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here which is
good for Magnus as he was uh only able
to get a draw in the first game he
played against um Grand Master from
Montenegro Nikita Petrov uh who was also
some 300 points lower rated but he was
able to get a draw here and here you
just resign there's no defense against
H4 whatever you play Just H4 uh the pawn
is defended and now H3 H2 H1 will bring
Magnus a queen into the game so uh very
interesting game Magnus not really
looking for any sort of a novelty in the
opening he just gave up a bishop for
Knight and then played a played a normal
game then he spent a bit too much time
and in the end he blundered so very very
official like game for Magnus we'll see
what happens in round three and like I
said use that hashtag suggestion uh in
order for me to spot all of those games
that I miss and uh you know for us to
check out a variety of players uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it as usual sorry I would like
to thank Jack schroer s Adia Isaac Davis
Martin gor pap Timothy Rosen for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up
what's happening in the F World rapid
championship and of course checking up
on your uh suggestions uh thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day